time for my first guest she became
america's mom on shows like the middle
and everybody loves raymond now she has
a new book out called your second act
let's give it up for patricia heaton
what's up girl hi
kelly how are you i i i'm
good i'm good i think we're all hanging
in there with all the things
happening in everyone's lives right now
the pandemic everything and everything's
crazy and different
um and for nine or ten months like since
you've been on our show so where are you
right now oh my gosh well i right now
i'm in la
okay um when the pandemic hit
uh my husband and i were producing and
husband directing a movie
that we are uh financing in oklahoma
city
and so we had five days left
and the basketball player rudy gobert
who has had been making
fun of the virus came down with the
virus
and he was staying in our hotel he was
staying in our hotel
so they had to evacuate the hotel and
then we had to shut down the production
with five days left oh my gosh what
about
this five days left that's horrible yes
oh my god well so what have you
what have you been doing i hear you've
been baking a lot well yeah
i mean um i you know we came home
um two of my sons were working on the
movie so they came home with me
and then i have another son that was in
school here in l.a so now i have i went
from empty nest
back to having three of my four sons at
home that's kind of cool
it's kind of cool yeah and um you know i
i
have a i had a cookbook out a while ago
and that's come in handy and
i wish you were here because you know
we've got some
we've got some apple pie muffins here
that are really good no i saw apple pie
i have apple pie muffins they i walked
into my house today and i saw a basket
of muffins i was like is this for the
show
yes because they go really nice with
coffee
my show knows i love sunflowers and
they're stupid
so i'm trying one and they have big
chunks of apple and them on there
i love apples and they're very easy okay
wait i'm gonna try it
okay looks good right gosh i love the
chunk of apple
right nice big chunks of apple mm-hmm
yeah yeah so i've been doing a lot of
that
um i'm not kidding this is not the tv
show this is
really good let's just eat for the rest
of the year
oh my gosh oh my gosh yeah
so did you did y'all celebrate anything
like during luck that we
i have birthdays you know here's the
thing um
in july it was two years since i've had
a drink
because uh two years because
um as we said i don't think i'm gonna
have grandkids for many many years
and i when they come i'll probably be
about 75
and so i need my brain like i don't want
to be that drooling
grandmother in the corner you know that
you have to go
kiss and then run away from i want to be
an active level you know so
so i haven't been drinking to preserve
my brain
right yeah however it doesn't seem to
have helped that much because
um the other night
i get a text from my youngest son and he
says
well happy birthday to me i guess
and i realized my mother did this once
and not only what it was at his birthday
it was his 21st
birthday oh no
i'm at the top of the stairs this was
like before the pandemic so he was still
at school
i yelled down i killed down the stairs
dave
we forgot dan's birthday dave's like oh
my god
so i at its 21st birthday so i felt
so so bad that i started texting every
celebrity friend that i had and i gave
them dan's phone number
and i um said please will you text my
son dennis's 21st birthday i forgot
please just text him wish him happy
birthday tell him tell him i'm a
terrible parent
and he dan was very impressed first of
all
uh his roommates at college were very
impressed that ashley tisdale was
texting him
so oh my gosh she's so that's so nice
and she was having a conversation with
her she told me later her husband said
who are you texting and she said a bunch
of college boys
but the best one was ray romano
sent me a video or sent dan a video and
then he said it to me and it's
really funny what he said i think you
have it
hey dan i know it's a little noisy
uh i'd understand it's your 21st
birthday according to my calendar
i i guess your your parents don't have
the same calendar that i do
but i keep track of things so happy 21st
birthday
um so it's speaking of ray though the
last time you were on here you were
talking about that you were going to
maybe go play golf with
ray right did that ever happen it's not
happened in fact
um just last week is the first time i've
golfed in months because of the pandemic
so um yeah i know i think he was just at
pebble beach but i haven't um
haven't been able to golf with him i
want his life okay he's just like
hanging out with a pebble beach
so patricia besides baking have you been
working on anything else at home
my spanish i started taking spanish
through an app through duolingo
me too yes but unless you like immerse
yourself because so here's the thing
i can read it really well and i can
speak it like if i'm like
you know but and when it comes to
communication it's so
fast i can't i lose it i don't i don't
know the difference between one word
or if it's like two different words
because they say it so fast well the
woman's voice on it when you have to
repeat what they say
or you have to type what she said she's
tricky because she
likes mushes words together i'm like
slow down
i know and if i'm not looking at it
that's that's the only thing is i'm
really good at looking at it my memory
of vocabulary is all right but it's
and i'm still like early on because i
have a lot going on but i just mean like
i can't the communication part i'm like
whoa that is so hard
and i love how the owl shames you like
he'll email you
like he will email you and be like we
miss you tyr and i'm like oh my god i'm
getting shamed by an app
you know you make a mistake and he
floats onto your screen and goes
hang in there hang in there loser like
it's like
thank you like um okay well you've got a
new book out and it's called your second
act so
obviously the title infer is what it's
probably about but go ahead and tell us
well interestingly enough it was
inspired by my now cancelled tv show
carol second half
i love you
i'm like what wait what
so um but actually it kind of is
appropriate because now i'm having to
like
do that next thing but yes the fact is
a lot of people during this pandemic
they've either
lost their job through no fault of their
own because of the pandemic
or they've been working at something for
a long time
and they've had this these months to
just reflect on their lives
and look at listen we've all seen how
sort of precious life is and how
you know we can't take anything for
granted and so we know that we have to
really
um use our time on this planet
wisely and and to be doing what we
really want to do so i think a lot of
people have had time to reflect and
think maybe when we all get back out
there again i might want to do something
different
and so this book is just really it's
like wonderful wonderful stories of
personal friends of mine and then just
some people we researched who have
changed their life usually because of
some unforeseen circumstance that came
into their life
and it's really inspiring it's little
changes like
an industrial carpet salesman who became
an actor
or it's huge changes like an nfl player
who became an opera singer
there's lots of different stories um
and there's pages in here where you can
take notes and start thinking about how
their stories inspire you maybe it's
sparking you
to start trying something new so um i
think it's a good time
for the for this book because uh i think
people need some inspiration
so do you think that the pandemic you
think the your world view
i feel like everybody like you're saying
we're all kind of having
i don't know a different perspective you
think that's totally i
i right now you know we're we're
starting to think about really making
some big changes in our life and just
figuring out
what we want to do we loved producing
this movie and we're
really excited about hopefully finishing
it before the end of the year
yeah but that's a direction and that's a
new direction for me to go and just be
behind the camera
um you know assist my husband and
um i loved it i loved being behind the
camera oh my gosh i just thought
watching these actors who have to really
g it up
every time and i mean i kept thinking
why did i think acting was fun because
i'm watching these actors and i'm so
relieved i'm not
doing it right now but i mean of course
i love acting and i you know be fun to
do another show but
but i'm really digging this producing
thing a lot
so you know we'll we'll see what happens
it's it's
i you have to look at it as an exciting
challenge as opposed to yeah approaching
these new things with fear you have to
sort of like
open yourself up and allow it to come in
and and embrace it and see where it
takes you
see where it takes you uh honestly like
and my
i don't care if we enter this or not but
and i think my life specifically right
now like there's just a lot going on
and and it's one of those things where
you can get down about it but i also
have this conversation with myself and
i'm like
you know what this is opportunity and i
know it's challenging and i know it's
not exactly what
anyone planned or whatever but it's one
of those things i like the messaging of
your book too and this whole
pandemic and perspective is literally
that
there's it's okay like opportunity
presents itself you have no idea
what what that will be and you have no
idea what beauty might come from
the you know darkness or the hard times
and i think that's really cool
about i love the whole i love that you
named it second action you said it's off
your
cancelled show but it's that's that
makes you one of my favorite people ever
just your humor
but um but i think it's a really good
message and i think you're right i think
it's more important now than ever
for people to have that so thank you so
much for coming on my show again
thank you for having me it's so good to
see you it's good to see you too
and everybody you can get patricia's new
book now it's called your second act
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going